an area  north of tampa bay is under quarantine  this morning but it's not because of  what you think it's thanks to the  rediscovery of a really really nasty  invasive pest take a look at this it's a  giant do we have to  you do it's a giant african land snail  which grows to be eight inches long and  can breed like you wouldn't believe it  was found in port richey florida yes it  does breathe is that what it's doing  right there i don't know because that  looks oh i don't think it's greedy  moment  pasco county under quarantine officials  i believe that the sales have been  driven out the area look they're very  tasty i've had them when i was living in  africa and i had a picture i can't find  it but i will share teeth with you it is  wonderful  lots of garlic and butter that's right  we'll be right back